[موسيقى]
جزاء الغيم تنهمر الحروف
لها نغم يحس به الشغوف
يرى فيها غصونا باسقات
على اطرافها تدنو القطوف
فان لبثت مقاليد المعاني مسطره تنوء بها
الرفوف
فتحنا في صميم العلم بابابا فقال الدهر قد
جاز الوقوف
[موسيقى]
يما الى ذروه العز التي قصرت عن مثلها عرب
الاسلام والعجم السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]
وردت كلمه طائر في القران العظيم بلفظ
موحد ومعان مختلفه وما من دابه في الارض
ولا طائر يطير بجناحيه الا امم امثالكم
ذلك في الانعام ويراد بالطائر هناك كل
محلق في الهواء بجناحيه
وكل انسان الزمناه طائره في عنقه ونخرج له
يوم القيامه كتابا يلقاه منشورا هذه في
الاسراء والمراد بطائره هنا عمله ونصيبه
من السعاده والشقاء
قالوا طائركم معكم اء ذكرتم بل انتم قوم
مسرفون هذه في سوره ياسين ومعنى طائركم
هنا شؤمكم فالمقصد شؤمكم منكم وملازم لكم
[موسيقى]
قيل ان عثمان رضي الله عنه لم يمارس
الخطابه قبل خلافته فلما صعد المنبر اول
مره ارتجى عليه بعض الوقت ثم قال الحمد
لله
والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله اما بعد
فان اول كل مركب صعب وان ابا بكر وعمر
كانا يعدان لهذا الامر معدا وان يمتد بي
الامد تاتيكم الخطب كابرا عن كابر وانكم
الى امير فعال احوج منكم الى امير قوال
والسلام
فاستحسن الناس هذه الخطبه وراوها احسن
واجزل واجمل من الخطب الطوال وطبعا دائما
البيان والبلاغه هو ان توجز في غير نقص
ولا اخلال فاحيانا تاتيك خطبه قصيره
ولكنها ماتعه جامعه
[موسيقى]
ما الفرق بين الشجاعه والتهور يراد
بالشجاعه الصلابه والشده عند الباس
والثبات في حزم اما التهور فاقتحام الامور
على غير بينه والوقوع فيها بلا مبالاه تعد
الشجاعه من ارفع القيم واعلى المناقب في
حين يعد التهور نقصا ومثلبه يقول ابو
الطيب الراي قبل شجاعه الشجعان هو اول وهي
المحل الثاني فاذا هم اجتمعا لنفس حره
بلغت من العلياء كل مكان ولربما طعن الفتى
اقرانه بالراي قبل تطاعن الاقران لولا
العقول لكان ادنى ضيق منه ادنى الى شرف من
الانسان
[موسيقى]
قال الحميدي كنا في مجلس عند سفيان ابن
عيينه فحدثنا بحديث زمزم لما شرب له فخرج
رجل من المجلس ثم رجع وعندما اوشك المجلس
على الانفضاض قال الرجل يا ابا محمد اليس
حديث زمزم الذي حدثتنا به صحيحا فرد سفيان
بلى فقال الرجل فقد خرجت فور سماعي وشربت
دلوا من زمزم علانيه ان تحدثني بمئه حديث
فقال سفيان اجلس وبدا يحدثه والرجل يعد
حتى اكتملت مئه حديث
اولئك ابائي فجئني بمثلهم
[موسيقى]
يروى ان هشام بن عبد الملك بن مروان حج في
ولايه ابيه او اخيه
وفي الحج كان معه نفر من اهل الشام كان
اذا اراد ان يستلم الحجر الاسود ربما
استعصى عليه الامر من ازدحام الحجاج هناك
وعلى عاده الخلفاء وابناء الخلفاء كانت
تضرب له قبه هناك
وبينما هو جالس في نفر من اهل الشام اذا
برجل جميل الهيئه جميل الملبس طيب الرائحه
قد اجتمع من حوله الناس وابدوا له علامات
التوقير وكان اذا اراد ان يستلم الحجر
الاسود افسحوا له من اجل ان يستلم
فسال اهل الشام من هذا وقال هشام لا اعرف
وكان هشام يعرف ولكنه خشي ان يقول هو فلان
فينصرف الناس اليه وكان بين اهل الشام
الفرزدق شاعر بني اميه فقال الفرزدق ولكني
اعرف فقيل من هذا يا ابا فراس فانشا قائلا
هذا الذي تعرف البطحاء وطاته والبيت يعرفه
والحل والحرم هذا ابن خير عباد الله كلهم
هذا التقي النقي الطاهر العلم هذا ابن
فاطمه ان كنت تجهله بجده انبياء الله قد
ختموا ينمى الى ذروه العز التي قصرت من
دونها عرب الاسلام والعجم يكاد يمسكه
عرفان راحته ركن الحطيم اذا ما قام يستلم
يغضي حياء ويغضى من مهابته فما يكلم الا
حين يبتسم ما قال لا قط الا في تشهده لولا
التشهد كانت لاهوك نعم
اذا راته قريش قال قائلها الى مكارم هذا
ينتهي الكرم
والحديث كما تعرفون عن زين العابدين
الامام علي ابن الحسين ابن علي ابن ابي
طالب رضي الله عنهم جميعا
[موسيقى]
يقولون هجانه يريدون مجموعه من الناس
يستخدمون الابل في تنقلاتهم وهو من فصيح
كلامهم وان لم يكن على اوزان الجمع
المشهوره فقد اجاز مجمع اللغه العربيه
بالقاهره زياده التاء المربوطه على بعض
الكلمات المفرده للدلاله على الجمع نظرا
لكثره ورود هذه الزياده في كلام العرب
وبخاصه في اسماء المهن والفرق كقولنا
خياله لمجموعه من راكبي الخيل ولبانه
للذين يبيعون اللبن وحطابه للذين يجمعون
الحطب
ولكن قبل نجمع القاهره ب 1400 سنه نزل
كتاب الله من فوق سبع سماوات بقوله تعالى
وجاءت سياره فارسلوا واردهم فادلى دلوه
وسياره هنا جمع السيار يعني جاء سائرون
فجمعهم القران الكريم بلفظه سياره
لا تقل خدمات وقل خدمات بكسر الخاء
الاولى جمع خدمه بالتحريك وتعني الخلخال
الذي تحلي به المراه ساقها يقول كثير بن
عبد الرحمن وان بظلام الليل اخفين مشيه
ابت خدمات الساق كتما فرنتي
والثانيه وهي الخدمه او الخدمات جمع خدمه
بالكسر وهي ما يسدى على وجه الاكرام او
تقديم المساعده لا تقل مطلع بالمسؤوليه
دون زياده الضاد مدغمه في الطاء لان كلمه
مطلع بتشديد الطاء تفيد العلم والكشف
بينما تفيد الثانيه التي مع الضاد
بالجداره والقوه والنهوض والتحمل ومنه قول
جرير في عمر بن عبد العزيز لما راوك بحمل
الكل مطلعا ضخم الدسيعه مامون الاداذان
[موسيقى]
وصف اعرابي قوما فقال اولئك قوم ادبتهم
الحكمه واحكمتهم التجارب ولم تغرورهم
السلامه المنطويه على الهلكه ورحل عنهم
التسويف الذي قطع الناس به مسافه اجالهم
فقالت السنتهم بالوعد وانبسطت ايديهم
بالانجاز فاحسنوا المقال وشفعوه بالفعل
وقيل افه المروءه خلف الوعد وكان عوف ابن
النعمان الشيباني يقول في الجاهليه لان
اموت عطشا احب الي من ان اموت مخلافا
لموعده ويقول اياس بن معاويه لان يكون في
فعال الرجل فضلا عن قوله اجمل من ان يكون
في قوله فضلا عن فعاله
[موسيقى]
بعض الناس يحبونك اليوم ويكرهونك غدا
ويتلونون في امزجتهم معتقدين ان هذا من
حريه المرء في حين ان الحر يرعى وداد لحظه
اخلاق البغال يضرب مثلا لمن يكثر التلون
يقول الجاحظ لما كان البغل من الخلق
المركب والطبائع المؤلفه والاخلاق
المختلفه تلون في اخلاقه الكثيره العيوب
المتولده عن مزاجه وشر الطباع ما تجاذبته
الاعراق المتضاده والاخلاق المتفاوته
والعناصر المتباعده وقال في موضع اخر
البغل اعزكم الله كثير التلون وبه يضرب
المثل يقول البحتري يهجو قوما لهم حلل
حسنه فهن بيض واخلاق سمجنفهن سود واخلاق
البغال فكل يوم يعن لبعضهم خلق جديد
[موسيقى]
كنت قد سالتكم في تويتر ماذا قالت العرب
في القهوه
سالتكم ذلك طبعا لانه ابيات القهوه جميله
عموما فحاولت ان اجمعها كلها تحت هذه
التغريده ولانني ايضا انا يعني مثل بقيه
الناس من محبي القهوه
هذه مشاركه من الدكتور فيصل ابو طفيله
يقول لولا ارتشافنا لاكواب من القهوه
لانتهبتنا الغفوه غنيمه بارده
ووضع اسمه تحت هذا القول اشاره الى انه هو
صاحب العباره
رهف بسام تقول وردت لفظه القهوه في الشعر
قديما بمعنى الخمره نجد ذلك في قول ابي
نواس يا خاطب القهوه الصهباء يمهرها
بالرتل ياخذ منها ملئه ذهبا يا قهوه حرمت
الا على رجل
اسرى فاتلف فيها المال والنشب
ومشاركه من يوسف يقول
يكاد ويفسد صومي ريح راغيه فوق اللهيب
حشاها البن والهال
يقول البيت لحذيفه الجابري ممنوعات ادبيه
وقد حرف بيت عمرو بن كلثوم وقال ونشرب ان
شربنا البن مرا
ونشرب ان شربنا البن مرا ويشرب غيرنا
بيبسي وكولا
فيصل ابن فلاح المري يقول فنجانها يشدي
خضاها بالخونداه
الجادل اللي عنده اهلها طموحي
الخونداه يعني المراه الجميله الجاهل هي
نفسها عندها جدايل عندها اهلها طموحي
تنتظر نصيبي يعني والله اعلم فهو يشبه
فنجان القهوه
بخضاب هذه الفتاه خطاب يعني الحناء التي
ترسمها وتتزين بها
الفتيات يشبه فنجان القهوه بهذه الخطاب
هذا من الابيات الشعبيه المشهوره جدا
ابيات شعبيه اخرى جابها باسل المسعودي في
هذه المشاركه
للشاعر عبد الله بن عون قم صب لي شعيل
منها فناجيل على سنه ضو تهادى ولعها اظنها
يا مال طول التماهيل تقلع همومي كان ربي
يقلعها
المهندس ابو النور يقول القهوه هي لغه في
حد ذاتها يا سلام
وبذور تقول ونصطاد الرؤوس بكل سههم رماه
البن من قوس الدلال
اكثر ما علي يقول وضع السكر خيانه للقهوه
وانا اتفق ايضا من حديثنا هنا عن التركش
القهوه السوداء يعني اما القهوه الشقراء
فهي ايضا فهي اصلا بدون يعني بدون سكر ولا
يوضع لها شيء من السكر
خالد يقول هي السوداء وفصلت في هواها نفيس
الوقت تحظى
بالهناء وعبد الرحمن يقول فنجان باليد ولا
عشره بالركوه
فنجان بالايد ولا عشره على الشجره
اشكر لكم هذه المشاركات طبعا انا يعني اذا
كان لي ان اشارك
فتعرفون ابياتي في القهوه تلك التي اقول
فيها يا قهوه الليل الذي سئم السرى هل في
المياه بقيه من نار كم تشبهين قصيده مرت
بنا يوم افترقنا عند باب الدار سوداء
تعلوها المراره انما في مائها شيء من
التذكار
[موسيقى]
هذا شاعر رفع نفسه قبل موته بايام قليله
فترك لنا قصيده من اجمل قصائد الرثاء التي
عرفتها دواوين العرب يقول في مطلعها الا
ليت شاريها الابي تن ليله بوعد الغضا
اسجد خلاص النواجي
عاش مالك بن الريب في عصر معاويه بن ابي
سفيان
تنبئن الاخبار القليله التي وصلتنا عنه
انه كان حسن المنبت ولكنه صار لصا فاتكا
يقطع الطريق وانتهى به الامر الى ان فر من
موطنه بباديه السمينه عند البصره الى بلاد
فارس وهناك اقام زمنا ومر بتلك البلاد
القائد الاموي سعيد بن عثمان بن عفان فلقي
مالكا فراى رجلا من اجمل الناس وجها
واحسنهم ثوبا فقال له ويحك ما دعاك الى ما
بلغني عنك من الفساد فقال مالك بن الريب
العجز عن المعالي وعن مساواه ذوي المروءات
وانني اريد مكافاه اخواني
فاستصحبه سعيد في جيشه واجرى عليه جرايه
في كل شهر
انطلق مالك بن الريب مع الجيش الى خراسان
تاركا بنتا له وصبيه صغارا يذكر كيف تعلقت
به ابنته وهو خارج مع الجيش ويصف دمعها
الذي يكاد يجرح خديها ثم يذكر ما صنعته
دموعها في قلبه ولقد قلت لابنتي وهي تكوي
بدخيل الهموم قلبا كئيبا وهي تدري على
الخدين من لوعه الفراق غروبها عبرات يكدنا
يجرحن ما جزنا به او يدعن فيه ندوبا
اسكتي قد حززتي بالدمع قلبي
طالما حز دمعكن القلوب
ودعي ان تقطعي الان قلبي او تريني في
رحلتي تعذيبا انا في قبضه الاله اذا كنت
بعيدا او كنت منك قريبا كم راينا امرا اتى
من بعيد
ومقيما على الفراش اصيب
وخرج مالك الى خراسان وغزا ولم يصب باذى
وفي طريق العوده مرض مرضا شديدا فتخلف عن
الجند وبقي معه صاحبان ولم يطل مرضه مات
مالك ابن الريب على فراشه لكنه قبل موته
قال قصيده رثى بها نفسه قصيده ظلت حيه في
ديوان الشعر العربي يذكر فيها اهله وفرسه
الاشقر الخنزير الضخم
الا ليت شعري هل ابيتن ليله بجنب الغضى
ازجى القلاص النواجيه الم ترني بعت
الضلاله بالهدى واصبحت في جيش ابن عفان
غازيا فلله دري يوم اترك طائعا بني باعلى
الرقمتين وماليا
الذين تعلقا بثوبي وقد ايقنت الا تلاقيا
تذكرت من يبكي علي فلم اجد سوى السيف
والرمح الرديني باكيا واشقر خنديدا يجر
عنانه الى الماء لم يترك له الدهر ساقيا
ولكن باطراف السمينه نسوه عزيز عليهن
العشيه مابيا تقول ابنتي لما رات واشك
رحلتي صفارك هذا تاركي لا اباليا ويا
صاحبي رحلي دنى الموت فانزلاه برابيه اني
مقيم اللياليا
وقوما اذا مستل روحي فهيئا لي القبر
والاكفى على ثم ابكي عليا ولا تحسداني
بارك الله فيكما من الارض ذات العرض ان
توسعا ليا خذاني فجراني ببردي اليكما فقد
كنت قبل اليوم صعبا قياديا
خذاني فجراني بثوبي اليكما فقد كنت قبل
اليوم صعبا قياديا
[موسيقى]
اقرا وضج الكون بالكلمات
وابعث قريشا بعد طول سباتي يا ايها الامي
جئت مصدقا بالذكر والانجيل والتوراه
السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]